indem du dieses videos bist du ein opfer
von künstlicher intelligenz ki geworden
wir sind tatsächlich wehrlos
ausgeliefert immer wieder gibt es fälle
die zeigen dass k extrem gefährlich ist
diskriminierung überwachung und
manipulation der ki selbst sind nur
einige stichworte dazu jetzt will die
europäische union eingreift 26 future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los ging's an künstlicher
intelligenz führt kein weg vorbei jede
und jeder von uns kommt bereits jetzt
immer wieder mit künstlicher intelligenz
in berührung das manchmal vielleicht
sogar ohne dass wir es bewusst
mitbekommen
allein in den sozialen medien spielt die
eine entscheidende rolle denn sie
entscheidet beispielsweise welche
werbung uns auf facebook angezeigt wird
oder welches video wir auf youtube
empfohlen bekommen aber auch wenn wir
uns für einen neuen job bewerben hat die
ki ihre finger im spiel in bestimmten
system ist sie es nämlich die innerhalb
der bewerbungsprozesse eine vorauswahl
trifft auch im bereich versicherungen
und banken ist künstliche intelligenz
nicht mehr wegzudenken nicht mehr die
bankerin oder banker entscheiden
zunehmend welche personen an kredit in
welcher höhe bekommen sondern die
künstliche intelligenz diese beispiele
machen klar dass die unseren alltag und
unser leben enorm erleichtern kann aber
eben auch das gegenteil menschen werden
in ihren jobs durch solche technologien
unterstützt und entscheidungen können
schneller getroffen werden
eine beratungsfirma hatte im herbst des
vergangenen jahres 2009 10 600
unternehmens vertreterinnen und
vertreter in bezug auf künstliche
intelligenz befragt großes potenzial
bietet diese nach ansicht der befragten
hauptsächlich bei der
effizienzsteigerung und der verbesserung
von prozessen vor allem in der
logistikbranche der produktion der
sicherheit und überwachung sehen die
befragten die künstliche intelligenz als
mögliche unterstützung
doch welche regeln gelten bei diesen
ganzen prozessen was darf die künstliche
intelligenz und was darf sie nicht in
welchem rahmen bewegt sie sich und nach
welchen spielregeln klar ist jedenfalls
dass sie auch zur bedrohung werden kann
auch dafür gibt es einige beispiele ein
besonders extremer fall
den gibt es in china hier wird ki
verwendet um die
gerinnen und bürger zu überwachen die
rede ist vom sogenannten social credit
system ein daten basiertes system mit
dem nicht nur die menschen sondern auch
unternehmen und behörden kontrolliert
und gesteuert werden können die
regierung möchte mit hilfe von
künstlicher intelligenz das moralische
politische finanzielle und soziale
verhalten überwachen und regulieren
pluspunkte können die chinesen und
chinesinnen möglicherweise schon in
naher zukunft sammeln indem sie nett zu
ihren nachbarn sind und häufig ihre
eltern besuchen eine hohe
spendenbereitschaft und ein ordentliches
verhalten im straßenverkehr werden auch
belohnt - punkte dagegen beispielsweise
gibt es wenn man sich in den sozialen
netzwerken danebenbenimmt wer dann nicht
in die kategorie ab guter mensch gehört
kommt auf die schwarze liste und könnte
unter anderem schwierigkeiten bei der
wohnungssuche bekommen big data und big
brother könnten in china in der nahen
zukunft bereits zur massenüberwachung
schlechthin führen das ziel des ganzen
vorhabens das derzeit bereits in
pilotprojekten getestet wird zitat die
vertrauenswürdigen sollen frei unter dem
himmel umherziehen können während es den
in verruf geratenen schwer gemacht wird
einen einzigen schritt zu tun
hinzu kommt auch daten geschützte
prognosen sind nicht immer zuverlässig
auch hier kann es zu fehlern kommen mit
schwerwiegenden konsequenzen sowie bei
dem folgenden fall die journalisten
vereinigung pro publica hatte eine
software genauer ins visier genommen die
das risiko berechnen soll inwieweit
einzelne strafgefangene wieder
rückfällig werden könnten dabei kam ein
haarsträubend das ergebnis heraus die
künstliche intelligenz nahm die
hautfarbe der menschen als
entscheidendes merkmal dafür an
krimineller energie auszuüben das hatte
der algorithmus so aus den trainings
daten abgeleitet und auch das hatte
damals fatale folgen ein ähnlicher fall
war ein algorithmus den krankenkassen in
den usa millionenfach angesetzt hatten
die software war dafür zuständig über
den weiteren behandlung bedarf der
patienten und patientinnen zu
entscheiden im einzelnen ging es darum
diejenigen kranken auszuwählen die eine
intensivere medizinische betreuung
bekommen sollten doch eine analyse ergab
dass der algorithmus alles andere als
unvoreingenommen war die software
diskriminierte schwarze patientinnen und
patienten und stufte sie deutlich
seltener als die hellhäutigen patienten
und patientinnen in höhe
risikoklassen ein im klartext bedeutet
das bei einem vergleichbaren
gesundheitszustand bekommen hellhäutige
menschen deutlich öfter die bewilligung
für eine intensive medizinische
betreuung als die schwarzen und die ki
hat eine weitere schwachstelle die wir
im auge behalten müssen denn künstliche
intelligenz ist entgegen der
landläufigen meinung keineswegs davor
gefeit selbst ausgetrickst zu werden
selbstlernender it sicherheitssysteme
können beispielsweise durch vergiftete
trainingsdaten manipuliert werden das
beispiel des sogenannten basic empfiehlt
das zeigt dies genauer bei diesem
statistischen verfahren handelt es sich
um einen mechanismus der spam-mails
blockiert mit bereits vorhandenen mails
wird er darauf trainiert mails in der
zukunft klassifizieren zu können doch
das kann schief laufen wenn ein
angreifer die möglichkeit bekommt
manipulierte mails in den lernvorgang zu
schleusen
so kann das modell quasi nach den
wünschen des hackers vergiftet werden
die spätere erkennung läuft dann nach
den vorstellungen des angreifers ab eine
eindeutige schwachstelle durch die eine
künstliche intelligenz relativ easy
manipuliert werden kann dennoch die ki
ist auf dem vormarsch auch hier bei uns
in deutschland nach angaben von apple
eine initiative zur förderung der
künstlichen intelligenz gab es im
frühjahr 2020 um die 250 jungen
unternehmen die ki in größerem umfang
einsetzen
das waren 15 prozent mehr als im jahr
zuvor 2009 10 die meisten dieser ki
startups gehören zu den bereichen
transport mobilität fertigung und dem
gesundheitswesen zwei drittel dieser cup
sind in berlin und münchen zu finden
doch das große problem hierbei europa
hat keine strategie in sachen ki und die
rechtssicherheit für startups und
konzern ist mehr als schlecht hier ist
die eu-kommission gefragt nach willen
des europaparlaments so schnell wie
möglich entsprechende
gesetzesinitiativen entwickeln soll
enthalten sein sollen ethische
prinzipien doch gleichzeitig wird auch
eine art überregulierung befürchtet dazu
sagt die vize präsidentin des
europaparlaments nicola beer von der fdp
in einem interview mit dem handelsblatt
wir dürfen nicht den fehler machen den
neu aufstrebenden
sektor in europa im kampf zu ersticken
weil wir alles bis ins letzte detail
regeln wollen neue technologien und
erfindungen brauchen luft und freiheit
um sie entwickeln zu können
sie und andere digitale politiker innen
fordern eine art haftungs system für
hochrisiko ki systeme im rahmen eines
risikobasierten ansatzes sollen
risikoreiche ki anwendungen wie
beispielsweise in der medizin oder
software die zur überwachung genutzt
werden kann
vorab auf ihre sicherheit geprüft werden
die eu kommission ist schon seit einiger
zeit dabei einen klaren und
berechenbaren rechtsrahmen zu schaffen
in der die nutzung der ki in der
europäischen union stattfinden kann und
dieses vorhaben ist nicht ohne denn zum
einen muss die rücksicht genommen werden
auf die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
die geschützt werden müssen
dennoch müssen innerhalb dieses
rechtsrahmens auch innovationen für
unternehmen möglich sein in einem knapp
40 seitigen papier haben sich
expertinnen und experten bereits im
april des vergangenen jahres 2019 dazu
geäußert die fachleute fordern eine
künstliche intelligenz der man vertrauen
kann und deren funktionsweise nicht
gegen gesetze verstößt zudem sollen
ethische prinzipien berücksichtigt
werden und die ki sollte möglichst auf
einem robusten gesellschaftlichen und
technischen rahmen beruhen das sind
klare unterschiede sowohl im vergleich
mit china aus auch mit den usa grob
gesagt wird die künstliche intelligenz
in den usa hauptsächlich von seiten der
unternehmen getrieben
in china ist es wie bereits am anfang
erzählt die regierung die mit hilfe der
ki kontrollieren und regulieren will
beide nationen befinden sie sich in
einem harten wettstreit um die
führungsrolle in der entwicklung und dem
einsatz der ki die eu-kommission setzt
dagegen den schwerpunkt darauf dass vor
allem die bedürfnisse und die rechte der
menschen im vordergrund stehen wenn
richtlinien in bezug auf künstliche
intelligenz formuliert werden
eine komplizierte geschichte denn hier
muss abgewogen werden der industrie muss
zum einen ermöglicht werden bei
technologischen neuerungen mitzuspielen
auf der anderen seite müssen die
unternehmen die interessen der
gesellschaft und die interessen der
privatpersonen berücksichtigen die
hoffnung der europäischen politikerinnen
und politiker ist es als eine art
vorbild für die anderen staaten zu
fungieren andere länder könnten also
europa schauen und die hier geltenden
regelungen als maßstab nehmen in dem
papier des gremiums wird vor allem
gefordert künstlich intelligente systeme
zu entwickeln die sich an die folgenden
vier grundprinzipien halten demnach soll
die ki erstens dringend
gesellschaftlichen schaden vermeiden
24 agieren drittens die menschliche
autonomie respektieren und viertens
zudem auch erklärbar bleiben personen
sollen dabei also das recht haben dass
wichtige entscheidungen nicht komplett
automatisiert getroffen werden wenn
diese dadurch benachteiligt würden wenn
also ein kredit von einem system
abgelehnt wird sollte die kundin oder
der kunde das recht haben mit dem
bankpersonal über diese entscheidung zu
sprechen oder bei youtube da kann die
entwicklungsabteilung nicht mehr
erklären warum der algorithmus bestimmte
dinge tut warum er ein video empfiehlt
oder ein anderes nicht also warum du
gerade dieses video hier siehst und
warum du es empfohlen bekommen hast und
dass es gar nicht gut die ki ist hier
unkontrolliert und vor allem
unkontrollierbar kontrolle aus damit
eine diskriminierung von menschen
verhindert werden kann müssen die
systeme nach ansicht der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vorsorglich bereits so entwickelt werden
dass diese gefahr minimiert wird firmen
sollten die ki deswegen vor ihrem
einsatz testen ob sie bestimmte
personengruppen abwertet oder
benachteiligt anhand einer checkliste
können sich die unternehmen orientieren
darin sind beispielsweise folgende
fragen enthalten wurde analysiert wie
das system in situationen und umgebung
reagiert die ihm unbekannt sind wird
verhindert dass sich menschen zu sehr
auf die ki und deren entscheidung
verlassen und sind die relevanten
datensätze tatsächlich repräsentativ
doch bin ist das bisher alles nicht die
eu kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen sagt dem europäischen
parlament algorithmen dürfen keine
blackbox sein und es muss klare regeln
geben für den fall dass etwas schiefgeht
sie fordert für die welt ein regelwerk
das den menschen in den mittelpunkt
stellt klar ist auch dass es hier um
viel geld geht europa hinter china und
den usa bei den privaten investitionen
immer noch hinterher die eu kommission
plant aber in zukunft pro jahr 20
milliarden euro in ki fließen zu lassen
auch auf nationaler ebene beschäftigen
sich fachleute damit eine
die strategie zu entwickeln erst ende
des vergangenen monats oktober 2020
hatte ein expertengremium aus bundestags
politikerinnen und politikern sowie
sachverständigen einen bericht an
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
übergeben nach zweijähriger arbeit
kommen die fachleute zu dem ergebnis
dass die ki zitat nicht per se schlecht
ist wichtig sei jedoch eine
demokratische gestaltung die zitat auf
der basis einer übereinkunft über gutes
und gerechtes leben für heute und für
zukünftige generationen ist die
eingesetzte enquete kommission soll dem
bundestag bei der ki strategie
empfehlung geben
hier geht es weiter mit roboter sofia
will menschheit zerstören anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran